how many log walls to Menard how do they
work I should put some volunteers in
remember what I said about at the start
it's easy it gets not I said someone a
volunteer one of the world wars anyone
hands up
say it again now say vlog a bit now what
do you mean by that log aim be like that
ok is equal to log a be good ok by the
way just while we've got it on the board
um test for you if you would have saved
this that exact line written say in an
exam what
hands up hands up
actually we took this way what do this
thing hands on your doctorate yet I'll
tell you do it like a countdown put your
hands on your head if you think it's
based a and put your hands on where else
can we do of course not cross your arms
it is based usually we should do hands
and lets you cross your arms if you
think is based an atomic cafe right
ready 1 2 3 the people whose hand the
big worship 10 are in good company
because our friends at kasi earth to
find loj just that as based him and you
can tell because if you've got your
calculator there on top of where it says
l OG what's on top of versatility knows
it it is tips of power off which is your
clue that when they say l OG it really
took about scientific notation that's
that's what's useful that's my face here
okay
however if you're not on you know that's
so such a mutation like kind of thing so
if you're a real mathematician and you
just write energy you actually mean
basically okay but to be unambiguous how
we normally write back and what if I say
you right now that stands for
yeah natural because he is the important
numbers here the last time or the time
for that we've got an e being the number
that was about what was it about its
equal to two point seven one or two in
order
but where did it come from it came from
the limit Oh Oh what kind of growth yeah
that's right and Y's are about the time
that exponential growth takes air that's
a conversation today bonus marks are
there a style ez bed this is dropping
but even a little bit this is the log
law what's the index law that's the
equivalent or the flip side of this log
wall because all the index laws or the
log Wars they're really the same thing
image you're looking for a few things
what's the equipment fly Marcus yeah
other Backman
good okay so the way you're seeing it
right
whenever I have trouble remembering what
the logins are I mean most people tend
to know their index laws quite well
because you're learning a lot earlier
okay so if you know this that's how you
get this
if you ever keep like is it adding
ghosts to multiplication or the other
way around right right your index law
and then you know it's the reverse for
the long haul okay all right so that's
kind of a hard one to start off with it
can someone give me a simple one what's
the
okay sure I'll pay it
it is true though it's kind of I'm sorry
yeah let the team down I am fine
you're really everything ready this way
because multiplication division same
deal just in Reverse okay another one
yeah good yeah by the way in some ways
it doesn't matter all that much but the
way I would read that is log base a of a
I find that a little bit ambiguous you
all would face a I'm actually reading
left to right it's true okay that's
three another one squared let's
generalize it shall we because this is
log rules right so suppose warrant
squared suppose it were to let's make it
in okay what city
okay
and all okay again what's the equivalent
in Dixville here hey let's try again was
the save just loud on buy goods you know
obviously you can do this for all of
them right
okay anything else to change a base yes
she's pretty cool how do you do change
of Base
let's do say log base a of B how would
you change the base okay
in some ways even then it's a tricky one
of the laws it's easy to even see
because I always picture is that the
video top amaze on the bottom so that's
what a returning to those are each what
base do you take the four to ten people
really love ten don't you answer is you
can take anymore
in fact you often see this okay with a
see down there signifying community
constant that looks pretty good
okay so we know lots of things about the
logs all of these laws that have elastic
would be familiar but can we
differentiate okay
so till you step back your night
subheading what was the derivative that
we looked at actually compare of
derivatives that we looked at last
lesson to remember we had a look at once
you come to me and then we looked at a
special case of the same formula and
remember derivative of something what do
we look at we were looking at broadly
speaking exponential functions with any
kind of base right well we particular
the to do with okay
what was it equal to yeah so that's what
we determined we used our calculators to
help us there's little bits of that kind
of thing and then the special version of
that and we look that lies in again okay
which is e to the X log e natural log n
which of course is just one and that's
what we got this from okay so now my
question is this is why we're working
all these laws might be if we understand
the exponential function right and
particularly the natural log function is
really just the flip side the inverse
function called the exponential okay if
you do some we have one just like here
where again this long rest of this law
you knew something out what it
necessarily tells you about the other
okay this is the way it always is in
math it's very symmetrical okay so my
question is
okay no I don't you shut up but does
anyone actually do the insult
I can't tens a few of you right now
here's what I want you to do for those
of you who like even though people are
we doing Matt's okay for you I want you
to see if you can work it out this is
what I'm gonna remind you all that's a
definition of an actual wall okay just
on your own steam just play with that
see if you can come with anything
meaningful for those of you who do know
what the answer is I want you see if you
can prove it okay
go to seem anything with formulas except
for except for what's on the board okay
see if you get a proof